ça fait des jours qu'on cherche et qu'on
trouve rien dans cette foutue jungle et
à un moment donné tu en peut plus ou
alors je suis juste pas fait pour ça
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
moi là bas le plus dur c'était peut-être
physiquement par exemple certaines
galère de la forêt tropicale c'est les
petits insectes
je crois qu'ils s'appellent des aoûtats
qui viennent pondre des oeufs en fait
sous ta peau est sanctionné par tous
partout et en fait moi ça faisait partie
de mes premières appréhensions en mode
c'est sûr et descend sur mes journées
vous cela ne bouge pas boustouller 106
soit bleu sortir le bric c'est l'envoi
de mon étiquette de chemises elles
vachement gluante et le premier jour
c'était vraiment mon angoisse en bonne
voie allez-vous-en les sangsues en a
marre et où je faisais mon père
attention le deuxième jour on est à la
mode or il ya encore une aurait encore
une
en fait je suis très vite passer outre
en mode bon bah façon on n'a pas le
choix est ce que le tout le temps et
remontent dont on colle et se cachent
partout dans les endroits de merde est
vraiment très peu très peu de gros
animaux en fait c'est pas les gros
animaux qui font peur dans la jungle
c'est les tout petits à temps il ya des
défis
cette forme vous voyez le truc qui est
quand même assez fou c'est d'avoir pu
découvrir dans une zone où l'homme
n'avait pas encore foutu les pieds ne
serait ce que des gravures humaines ou
en fait qui date de au moins quinze
mille ans et on sait pas trop ce que ça
veut dire du coup c'est une découverte
rare c'est du hasard total ans est
vraiment c c'est trop c'est fou
[Musique]
pas
quand on pense pas pou je sens que je
demande à des gens dans la rue ils
disent assez les tribus l'a acquise dans
la forêt
et ils mangent des larves je viens
seulement de les rencontrer est ce que
je peux vous dire c'est que ce sont des
gens profondément gentil et par dessus
tout très timide mais pas pour
maintenant et vivent aussi en ville
l'école est obligatoire en papouasie
occidentale donc les familles ont dû
descendre ils gardent quand même leur
leur leur coutume c'est dire qu'il soit
avec des plantes mais n'oublie balles
manquantes on est monté avec eux dans
leurs villages ils avaient une machette
à la main un téléphone portable tous un
vin parle de ce choc un petit peu un
petit peu unique même dans l'histoire de
l'humanité
c'est à dire qu'ils étaient à l'âge de
pierre yahia je sais pas combien
d'années la très peu en fait et
maintenant il y en a ils peuvent prendre
l'avion mais j'en fais pas des casseurs
je vous jure le trait
[Musique]
on était dans les îles rajaona pâte dans
un espèce de lagon magnifique c'est très
paradisiaque c'est très cartes postales
en fait et a abandonné voilà comme comme
tout humain j'avais envie d'aller aux
toilettes et je me suis isolé un petit
peu pour aller pourrait trouver un
endroit pour et je suis tombé juste dans
cet endroit là le guide de la terre dans
un magnifique qui protégeait sur un
gobelet en plastique de vivre ça alors
que j'ai toujours vécu ça à travers les
reportages par exemple ou du témoignage
ne serait ce qu'au médiatique en fait
quand tu lui as devant toi et tu dis
mais attendons quand même à l'autre bout
de la terre et là je tombe sur un
gobelet céder trop coûteux là tu dis
[ __ ] ça me donne envie d'un peu plus
compliqué parce que je suis et ce qui
est sûr c'est que je viens de vivre
l'expérience la plus intense de ma vie
physiquement
humainement et émotionnellement